(lighthearted music)
- Yeah, the sheep are everything.
They're my employees,
they're my co-workers,
they're my livelihood.
I'm very much bonded to my animals
and I hope they're bonded to me,
hope they enjoy working with me
as much as I enjoy working with them.
My name is Zach Richardson
and I'm an urban shepherd.
I call myself an urban shepherd
because, I guess,
technically I'm a shepherd,
one who tends a flock of sheep.
But most of my projects are in the city.
(metal clanking)
(door squeaking)
Stay.
Urban grazing is the
strategic use of sheep
to manage overgrown landscapes
in an urban context.
Right now, I have a total
of 60 ewes, or female sheep.
Sheep will eat just about everything.
This site has about every invasive species
that's common in middle Tennessee.
You know, euonymus, English
ivy, privet, honeysuckle,
Japanese honeysuckle, Tree-of-heaven,
but they'll eat all of them.
Let's say you have an
overgrown piece of property.
You call me and you tell
me exactly the areas
that you're targeting.
And then we load up
some sheep on a trailer,
bring you a modest flock,
and they stay onsite until
the job is completed.
(whistling)
Duggie is the most important
component to my business.
He's more important than my truck,
he's more important than my trailer,
he’s almost more important than the sheep.
Now his job as a Border Collie
instinctively is to gather the sheep,
and he loves doing it.
You could throw a Jr. Whopper
at him when he's working
and he wouldn't care,
he just wants to keep working.
That'll do, here Duggie, lie down.
'Cause this is not a new concept you know,
moving sheep to clear land.
Here in the city we've forgotten
that this is even possible,
that this is an option.
It's deep down in all of us somewhere
to want to watch animals do what they do.
We've just kind of been removed from it.
It's therapeutic, isn't it?
Just watching sheep eat.